[Music]
a shooting that injured a School
employee is being linked to a gang
dispute that started at another school
Under report on the shooting just
outside of Von tobel Middle School
highlights violence between a couple of
rival gangs at the East Side High School
lawmakers at a hearing today in fact are
talking about how to stop School
violence like this recent incident a new
Zeal education reporter Joshua peguero
explains
in metro police report shows violence
escalated from Sunrise Mountain High
School to surrounding communities today
lawmakers discussed ab285 a piece of
legislation aimed to make it easier to
expel students I think there's a
difference between
individuals that are let's just say gang
motivated versus individual that has
anger issues uh post-traumatic stress
school psychologist Norris Dupree is an
advocate he testified before lawmakers
on why there needs to be a change to the
restorative justice law that passed in
2019 Democratic Assembly women Angie
Taylor is a sponsor of ab285 baby people
are safe but there's one thing to be
safe it's something else to feel safe
and teachers don't feel safe other
students don't feel safe the proposed
Bill makes it easier for teachers and
administrators to expel and suspend the
problem students it would also allow
kids under the age of 11 to be suspended
the Clark County Education Association
and its members support this bill and
I'll let us submit it to lawmakers the
teacher says a colleague at Del Sol
Academy was assaulted twice this year by
a student
ab285 also forces administrators to
create a behavioral plan for students
that includes positive intervention but
Republican state senator Kerry Buck says
she has issues with it oftentimes what
we end up doing is we make all these
rules for the kids that yes absolutely
they need Behavior plans behavior
supports But ultimately we punish the
ones that are doing the right thing
right now we don't have a date on when
the Senate education committee will vote
on this bill back to you guys